جلسه مهمه جدا حول الاوضاع الانسانيه في
ايران همم بدات بكلمه
لفولكر ترك المفوض السامي لحقوق الانسان
اشار فيها الى اعداد كبيره من القتلى
تجاوزت 300 حتى الان بالاضافه الى
اعتقالات شمالات اطفالا باعداد كبيره ايضا
هناك كذلك حسب ترك اعتقالات تجاوزت
الاربعه عشر الف شخصا الجلسه كل همم
عقدت بطلب مباشر من همم من المانيا
وايسلندا بالاضافه الى دعم عدد كبير من
الدول هناك مشاركه رفيعه المستوى كذلك من
عدد من الدول ابرزها وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه التي حضرت هذه الجلسه الى
جانبها كذلك حضر همم وزراء خارجيه هولندا
ولكسم برج شخصيات سياسيه مهمه ايضا هذه
الجلسه تركزت على الاوضاع الانسانيه على
الانتهاكات التي
تنتهيتها ايران بحق بحق المعترضين على
سياستها لاسيما بعد السادس عشر من سبتمبر
الماضي ومقتل مساء ميني الدول المشاركه
طالبت
بمحاسبه ايران على هذه الانتهاكات
وكذلك سيتم التصويت نهايه هذا هذه الجلسه
بعد ظهر اليوم على مشروع قرار من بين بدو-
بنوده تشكيل اللجنه التقصي حقائق تبحث في
خلفيات هذه الاعتقالات وعمليات القتل
والانتهاكات وبطبيعه الحال الجانب
الايراني رفض هذه التي هامات وقالت
المتحدث باسم الوفد الايراني انا مجلس
حقوق الانسان مخيب للامان وانا ايران اتخذ
التدابير فعليه على الارض بعد مقتل امين
انشاء لجنه التحقيق
لمتابعه هذه الاحداث اشير الى ان قعد
الدول ساندت الجانب الايراني مثل همم
مندوب سوريا في الامم المتحده مثلا في حين
اتجهت الصين الى طلب العمل الدبلوماسي
والاحاث الاطراف على التهدئه من دون
اللجوء الى اي تصعيد اضافي اذا الجلسه
مستمره حتى همم الرابع بعد ظهر على الاقل
بتوقيت باريس اليوم حيث سيتم التصويت على
مشروع القرار الذي يعتقد انه سيمر باكثريه
كبيره خلال هذه الجلسه شكرا جزيلا لك يا
دينا بالصابونه في ج